[Music]
hmm
i can release it for you but you'd have
to watch out for negative energy fields
and avoid mean reds yo listen up
i talked to dex while you were in with
the doc he's waiting in his ride
for you ain't gonna hop to where he's
parked
next to gramsci burgers okay do my best
to talk us up
what are you d listen i've got this
delicate matter that's why i called you
the number of cyber psychologists in the
city is on the rise
now that's probably not news to you but
this issue matters to me
for a few reasons there are people who
say cyberpsychosis can be treated
and i know exactly how that sounds but i
believe even an unproven therapy
is still better than a bullet to the
brain if i get a tip about a possible
attack i'll give you a call
maybe you can investigate before max
tack hits the scene
but remember you're not there to execute
anybody
try to incapacitate the attacker and
i'll send someone to pick them up
i hope that's all clear
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yo mr v a pleasure dexter deshawn in the
flesh
ample indeed
let's roll mind if i ask you something
right off the bangle
would you rather live in peace as mr
nobody die
right old and smelling slightly of urine
or go down for all times in a blaze of
glory smelling near like posies without
seeing your 30th
it's first place and no place dex cost
isn't a factor
classic i'd expect nothing less from
eager supple youth
respect right
listen close scanning a serious job now
playing gargantuan compared to smashing
up a scav home
let me hear it what's the job this
prototype tech a biochip to be precise
jobs to grab it simple
yeah guessing it belongs to a court
mm-hmm arisaka
surely that's no problem
no no problem just a death sentence
nc's arasaka's turf nobody [ __ ] with
them here
what can i say mr b high risk high
reward
first rule of the afterlife besides that
i'm no lead head ain't gonna leave no
trace for them to follow cause we're
gonna do this clean and on the hush hush
we understand each other you work this
out
got a plan two things first
a conundrum with the maelstrom boys
needs active resolving that
second to rendezvous simple client who
brought us the jobs anxious
she wants to parlay with one of the team
what's the issue needs resolving with
maelstrom got a beef
it's locked in the jar
i got a classic tail for you psycho gang
doing his thing two weeks back
jumped a military convoy got away with
the gear
corp don't even know maelstrom's
involved
now see convoy was carrying the flathead
a
little combat bot a prototype and i need
me that bit of high grade military tip
because if we don't get that body we
don't get no soccer chill
and we sure as hell don't get no happily
ever after
but don't get excited it's a single use
toy
now i slide out purchase the damn thing
from maelstrom
the problem is i did so from a gentleman
by the name of brick
i say win because brick was the leader
three days after we'd see the idea
his friend and gang mate one simon
randle aka royce
playing dropped his ass royce is in
charge now
and i got no way of knowing if he aims
to honor his predecessor's word
to add to this shitstream one meredith
style of militech has developed an
interest in said convoy
mr prima donna corporal agent internal
affairs
been skidding around town asking after
the convoy as if her life depended on
finding it
the one lead she's got zip tied in her
trunk stick up her ass ain't growing any
shorter
so she must be getting desperate be wise
to think how you could use that
of course to do so you'll need that
frazzled cat's info
sending it now client
what's her thing why she need to meet
woman's name's evelyn parker bettinger
wasn't easy
put the word out i was looking for any
kind of intel
right and some brothers from pacifica
got back to me
told me to stop looking in the convo
anyway our little client insisted on
meeting someone with skin in the game
you know who'll be there for it all
yours truly will be remote t-bug ain't
no people person and
jackie's only good at some things i know
you know what i mean
pretty much leave you
think i got everything time i got to
work
well that's just music to my ears i'll
set up the meet with miss parker at
lizzie's bar
flat head though is gonna be all you
one more thing mr b
quiet life or blaze of glory
later now
jagster talk to dex
a big deal literally
claim to want to check our pro crate but
to me it feels more like he tangled us
up with maelstrom and militech
there's this combat bot military
prototype maelstrom clapped it
then decks paid to take it off their
hands just before the gang goons had to
switch up in management
all right right heard about that royce
versus prick
that sums it up dex wants us talking to
royce
gave the deets of some militech agent
too but
i don't know how much help she stands to
be
then there's the other thing gotta meet
the client who put the job on the table
evelyn parker you oh what's dex gonna do
right around in his limo chat chicks up
on the hollow
parker wants to meet someone on the crew
dex gave me the nod
they must know what he's doing so how
you want to play this
bell strummer parker was first
i say we knock on maelstrom's door first
pound actually
in that case i'll hit the all foods put
my nose to the ground
sniff around hasta luego
you